in its most bizarre electoral strategy
since nominating a desiccated old crone
for president in 2016
Democrats have now taken to defending
face tattooed child slaughtering illegal
alien psychopath gangsters I'm sure that
one's gonna work out great November guys
we all analyzed which is worse ms-13 or
the MSM then Lord Conrad black joins to
discuss his new book Donald J Trump a
president like no other you can say that
again
and we will round out the news with my
least popular opinion of all time I will
finally alienate my entire audience by
explaining why Starbucks is terrific
finally the mailbag I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
Trump has gone he's gone too far this
time because he's criticizing criminals
we would with speaking of criminals
we'll get to that in a second we have
got to talk about the best home security
solution there is it's the new
neighborhood watch it's a great way to
keep track of your home when you're
either in the home or outside or at work
or on vacation it's just incredible ring
rings mission is to make neighborhoods
safer today over a million people use
the amazing ring video doorbell to help
protect their homes ring knows that home
security begins at the front door but it
doesn't end there so they've now
extended that same level of security to
the rest of your home with the ring
floodlight camera you probably know this
when you try to go burglarize people's
houses and you go to try to break in and
that light comes on from from the
floodlight well you look up with a new
ring floodlight camera there's actually
a little camera in there it will find
you it will find the bad guy it will
upload that video to the cloud so even
if you steal the floodlight camera
they'll still be in the cloud you can
share it with your neighbors it is
really cool I I've got one a bunch of my
friends use this it is the must-have
home item you can see and speak to
visitors you can even set off an alarm
right from your phone some guy comes
they you know I'm getting a lot of
wedding presents right now you can see
right there if someone tries to come and
steal your packages you can talk to them
you'll get alerts on your phone it's
really cool whether you're home or away
a ring floodlight cam lets you keep an
eye on your home from anywhere it offers
the ultimate in home security with high
visibility flood lights a powerful HD
camera that put security in your hands
with ring you're always at home get it
this thing is really cool it is the best
home accessory you know for home
security for seeing people out your door
it is really really cool right now don't
say I never did nothing for you save up
to $150 off a ring of security kit when
you go to ring.com
slash Knolls KO wles ring.com slash NOLs
KO wles what is it ring calm slash
Knolls KO WL e s trump has gone too far
this time guys he's just gone he's gone
too far it was bad enough when he
slaughtered half of the country with net
neutrality you know when they were
peeled net neutrality and everybody
literally died
and then then he reformed our tax code
he lowered people's taxes lowered the
corporate rate I don't know how many
people died in that but now he's gone
too far
Donald Trump is now criticizing
murderous psychopath gangsters it's too
far here are Donald Trump's comments
yeah an ms-13 gang member I know about
if they don't we just the best certain
threshold
I cannot tell ice about them we have
people coming into the country of trying
to come in we're stopping a lot of them
but we're taking people out of the
country you wouldn't believe how bad
these people are these aren't people
these are animals and we're taking them
out of the country at a level and at a
rate that's never happened before
and because of the weak laws they come
in fast we get them we release them we
get them again we bring them out it's
crazy the mainstream media are furious
that Donald Trump would say such a thing
that violent terrible criminals are
animals so we'll get to the headlines in
a second we'll get to the mainstream
media and the Democrat response in a
second first just a little bit of
context here's a quick rundown of some
of ms-13 s gang crimes from just this
year and last year last November Donald
Trump's administration arrested 200
members of this gang in America this
year we've arrested a hundred we don't
know how many gang members are in this
country it's a violent gang primarily
from El Salvador ms-13 here's a quick
rundown let's just look at this week on
Tuesday a man's body was discovered in a
shallow grave dug in a park in
Washington DC
ms-13 gang members dug that grave before
they stabbed the man more than 100 times
cut off his head and ripped out his
heart and then so Donald Trump called
those guys animals that mainstream media
they're furious they're furious
here are some other ms-13 gang crimes
just for last year ms-13 affiliate Venis
Romero tortured stabbed and killed a
fifteen year old girl for dating her
boyfriend in January of last year
another ms-13 gang member murdered 15
year old de Morris Alexandra raised
Rivas and by the way just notice
something here a lot of these victims
are Hispanic a lot of these victims
actually are immigrants from the same
places that this gang comes from so they
say oh it's a racist
you're talking about these these animals
accusing these people of the crimes that
they have obviously committed a lot of
the victims are from the same areas
they're from the same immigrant groups
another another crime Miguel Alvarez
Flores in Diego Hernandez Rivera
kidnapped sexually tortured and murdered
a teenage girl I was last February 3
ms-13 gang members stabbed and mutilated
17 year-old Raymond wood before running
him over with their car cutting off his
hands and leaving him for dead that was
in March also in March Hector Lazo and
Pedro Rivera shot 37 year old Nelson
Rodriguez in the back of the head he was
just walking down the street in April to
document 'add ms-13 gang members shot an
11-year old girl in two teenage boys in
Houston documented meaning we knew who
they were we knew they were here
illegally we knew that they were members
of this gang but we couldn't do anything
hard to do anything about that we
wouldn't want people to think that we
think of them as animals we that would
would that would be racist for some
reason or whatever the mainstream media
says in April of last year ms-13
gangsters wielding machetes mutilated
and murdered four victims between 16 and
20 around the same time as they murdered
seven others in the same neighborhoods
Alexi signs murdered three Long Island
high school students last year ms-13
gang member he attacked two young girls
at the same time when they were walking
through their suburban neighborhood a
three ms-13 gangsters were arrested last
May after they slashed a 19 year old
with a machete and shot him point-blank
ms-13 gang member Carlos Gonzales
murdered his girlfriend maritza Lopez
last year that guy is still at large I
could go I could go on for the whole
rest of this show with these peoples
crimes they are face tattooed demons
from hell
only God can judge people but the Donald
Trump administration can arrange the
meeting there's nothing wrong with that
and actually what in the more you read
about these crimes you realize that what
Donald Trump said is not true these
people are not animals they are much
much worse than animals because animals
aren't morally culpable for what they do
when the tiger eats the little animal in
the jungle that it's not that like the
tiger is sinning it's not like the tiger
has committed some immoral act it's just
in the tigers nature to eat other
animals but when human beings who have a
moral conscience when they mutilate
people kill
teenage girls maim cut off body parts
cut off heads when they do that they are
committing evil they are they are
pervaded by evil and when they should
know better when they do know better but
they choose to do evil things it's much
worse than animals
we should all be able to agree that
these guys are pretty bad right I think
that I think you know I know we're in a
time of political disagreement political
rancor I think we can all agree that
face tattooed gangsters who decapitate
little teenage girls probably those guys
are not good people right that's what
you would think how did the Democrats
and the mainstream media react they
defended the psychopath gangsters this
is so some of some of the headlines we
have here Trump lashed out at
undocumented immigrants during a White
House meeting calling those trying to
breach the country's borders animals who
saw this in the New York Times but he
wasn't lashing out at undocumented
immigrant lashing out at illegal aliens
he was lashing out at violent criminals
and this actually gets to an incredible
point of the mainstream media and the
Democrat party's bigotry which is that
they're conflating violent Psychopaths
gangsters with all illegal aliens Donald
Trump didn't do that he made a he was
very specific he said these people are
animals these people are sick monsters
and we got to get them out and the
mainstream media said you're calling all
illegal aliens all immigrants animals
all immigrants are less than human I
said what are you talking about I never
said that the illegal aliens are all
psychopath criminals you said that it
goes on Jennifer Rubin
said she writes for The Washington Post
she pretends to be a Republican she's
one of the biggest Democrat chills in
the entire country she tweeted quote
this is disgusting and Trump's
evangelical sycophants will applaud his
utter dehumanization of men women and
children I don't know how many little
girls are members of ms-13 I suspect
zero none of them are but this actress
this really lowers my estimation of
Jennifer Rubin I always thought she was
just one of those fake Republicans that
the mainstream media hires
so
that they can pretend that they have a
Republican opinion and they just use
that person constantly to criticize
Republicans but here she's just flat-out
lying I don't think she's stupid enough
to actually think that Donald Trump is
is saying something that he obviously
didn't say so here we just have a flat
outlier in Jennifer Rubin it's really
pathetic
from Andrea Mitchell at NBC but by the
way just a point on Andrea Mitchell it
took me approximately twenty four years
of my life on this earth to realize that
Andrea Mitchell and Mika Brzezinski are
not the same person did you know that
that they're not the same person it's
just that maybe other people realize it
this was news to me
so she tweets that quote a tough
takedown by the California Governor
after real Donald Trump calls people
trying to get into the country animals
not people again he didn't call people
trying to get it well he called some
people trying to get into the country
animals not people like they're vicious
gangsters and this gets to it an
important point of illegal immigration
some of the people trying to get into
our country are vicious gangster
criminals who should not be allowed in
she's she's actually unwittingly tried
to she's unwittingly made our point
right which is that it's not all just
really nice polite workers coming in who
are the the people entering our country
some of them are criminals some are
those bad people that Trump talked about
when he launched his campaign from
Bengie Sorrell and a political reporter
at NBC quote one of trumps most
consistent rhetorical moves is comparing
large classes of human beings to animals
a political tactic with a long and
deadly history I think he's making the
argument amad Hitler room at this point
you know any anybody who disagrees with
me is Hitler that's what he's saying
about Trump Chris Christian feat farias
from New York Magazine never ever forget
this fact Donald Trump reserves the word
animals only for brown people so what
you're saying buddy is that all brown
people are criminals that's what you're
saying you're saying that they're
animals and they're criminals but that's
not what Donald Trump is saying he's
saying some people are criminals and
those people are animals you're
conflating race and and crime it's not
the Republicans doing it it's not Donald
Trump doing it it's a you mainstream
media and drownded all that Tyler Hansen
from the d-trip the Democratic
Congressional Campaign Committee he
sends out these pictures of these little
the current kids these like sweet little
kids and crying parents says Trump we're
taking people out of the country you
wouldn't believe how bad these people
are these aren't people these are
animals so that's just a lie right he's
not talking about those people he's
talking about gangsters the mainstream
media the Democrats they're now
defending ms-13 the the strategy that
they have undertaken is to oppose
anything that Trump does the trouble for
them is the Trump is doing successful
and popular things on the economy on
foreign affairs on domestic affairs on
immigration so they're opposing that but
that leads them into these absurd
positions like defending ms-13 they're
not they say okay Trump likes kicking
out gangsters so so we need to bring
them into the country that then will
just do the opposite keep it up guys
keep it up Democrats good work yeah I
can't wait for November okay let's bring
on our guest Lord Conrad Black Conrad
Black is a member of the British House
of Lords
he's a financier a newspaper tycoon
historian biographer excellent columnist
I suggest you read his writings he has a
new book out I really really like this
book I highly recommend Donald J Trump a
president like no other this book has
just come out this week you have to read
it
Lorde black thank you for being here
thank you for having me Michael and I
want to say I agreed with everything
you've said in the part that I've seen
especially that beastly woman Jennifer
Rubin it's high time she was unmasked it
is it is so frustrating because I so
many times with these Republicans who
all they ever do is try to get Democrats
to like them I say okay you're
opportunistic that's fine but this is
outright lies and there are a lot of
lies about a president Donald Trump you
have written the best coverage of Donald
Trump that I have read this book is so
so good and it gives a perspective that
people are just not getting in the media
I want to delve into that some of the
lies some of the distortions that we
have let's begin with a sort of obvious
one a lot of people are telling us here
that Donald Trump is secretly an idiot
he's just a dummy he doesn't know
anything and he's just made it to the
highest points of real estate and
casinos and politics and television just
by luck or
by whatever what is it you you write
about how Donald Trump has a real genius
for real estate how did he manage to
make it to the top of that industry and
every other well in the case of real
estate he he had an absolutely tireless
devotion as he has said at times to
putting the deal together and it means
going to a bankrupt organization
persuading claimants and suitors to hand
over for some sort of consideration but
not not tangible and not upfront their
claims in respect real estate assets and
then and then shopping this around
through proper financial circles to get
building loans and municipal approvals
and approval of creditors and it is it
is an unbelievably exacting process but
his first big deal the old Commodore
hotel between the Chrysler Building in
Grand Central Station in New York that's
what he did and he didn't have anything
he said I have you're a signed contract
and it one of his many held press
conferences every days and and he was
just very young men and and he did have
a sign counter it was signed by him but
not by the other party even say that it
always puts you into the position of
being a bit of a huckster and and a
peddler and a slightly shabby middleman
but but if you stay at it hard enough
and there is ingenious at it as he was
well it couldn't have % you make a
fortune and and that's what he did and
now he got carried away and he ended up
for a time with a negative net worth but
he convened the bankers himself and he
ain't knew the last thing in the world
they wanted to do was call the loans
that have to acknowledge the assets
where we're going to be severely
devalued and the last thing in the world
a banker once said he was trying to run
a real estate business and all he had to
do was say look just sit tight I'll give
you all the pledge you only collateral I
can and this is my plan of action to
work my way out of this and that's what
happened and what you going back to what
you said about this allegation against
him of being essentially deep down he
shower
the fact is as I pointed out towards the
end of the book and thank you for your
kind words about it
he achieved more objectively speaking he
achieved more before he was inaugurated
president than any previous holder of
that office except Washington Jefferson
Madison grant and Eisenhower I'm not
denigrating the others most of the
others had serious careers some of them
very substantial like Woodrow Wilson at
Princeton University and so forth but
not like that not where you make
billions of dollars you've you've
decided to become a television performer
from day one and for 15 years without
one single interruption you're pulling
over 25 million viewers top slot every
week for 15 years except two nights
opposite American Idol and I never
watched that kind of television I'm not
what I've done as programs but that's
not the point he was a great success and
and to take over the Republican Party
either party but the only other person
who did this was Wendell Willkie where
you have never sought or held a public
office elected or non elected or a
military command and and you and you
take over the party Wilkie did it for
the great honor of running it against
Franklin Delano Roosevelt it was
invincible nobody could ever defeat and
and and Donald Trump did it and and then
and then he actually won this election
it was an astonishing feat and how
anyone I mean I understand why people
don't like them I understand why they
feel threatened by I understand how they
find him distasteful all about I
understood but to say that he is not an
accomplished and capable man is an
outrage and I love that the book is
actually rather even-handed there it's
there's no hiding I I think you admire
Donald Trump I admire Donald Trump but
the account is well the the fact of the
biography is that it is honest about hit
some of his flaws as you mentioned the
hucksterism you're you're quite open
about that even some of his business
failings some of his untruths that he's
told along the way you what university
was I mean it in one sense it's
magnificent if you've been actually in
that PT Burnham wave ever go bankrupt on
you know whose edge rating the
intelligence of the public but I mean
you
it's it's outrageous and it's but it's a
music but it is egregious it is I've
actually only been referring to Wharton
School in the University of Pennsylvania
as Trump University these days because I
know it bothers the students there but
but you write early on in the book you
say it is also Trump's nature honed by
the rough and tumble of his career
including observing his father's
business to believe that no competitive
activity beyond the playing field if
that is quite as pristine as represented
he is not so much a cynic as a
methodological agnostic not a liar as
much as a disbeliever in absolute
secular truths and there is a lot in
that sentence what do you mean by it
and what is Donald Trump's relationship
to the truth just and I'll take the last
part first if I may
you have to examine his relationship to
the truth in looking upon him as we are
or as a public figure and indeed as the
holder of the great office of president
of the US you have to examine it I think
at two levels at one level he has the
habits of his career and engages in what
he calls truthful hyperbole now how
truthful it is sometimes has opened a
legitimate question although often it's
partly truthful and he and he believes
in exaggerating in a manner that is
somewhat self-serving and he's only
slowly I think but definitely gradually
recognizing that if he scales that back
he'll he'll gain by doing so that he's
got he's got people watching and
listening so carefully many of them in
hostile to him that he's giving
ammunition to his enemies if he doesn't
if he doesn't reel it back a bit but on
the other level in terms of addressing
the country promising the country what
he will do if they elevate into this
supreme office it must be said that in
doing precisely what he promised to do
his record is absolutely historically
outstanding and not surpassed by anyone
else I mean he said he would pull out of
the Paris Accord it shocked people and
he did it but he did it he was right to
do it it's a ridiculous of court he said
he'd move the embassy in Israel he did
it and he was right to do it he said he
walked out of the Iran agreement
and even highly serious foreign policy
people said well it's no point during
that we've already given them the money
was a terrible agreement but why walk
out now but he's walking out in order to
Korean eyes the issue and really put the
heat on Iran to make a permanent
renunciation of nuclear weapons he's
absolutely right he said he would do it
it was controversial and in the case of
course of the Israeli embassy that has
been promised by several of his
predecessors who then didn't do anything
he said he would eliminate oil imports
he's doing it every president since
Eisenhower said that and some of them
were very good presidents but they
didn't do that he's doing so at that
level he absolutely is truthful and
well yeah that's right yeah I think you
you have you examine it on two planes
one is the traditional Donald Trump who
made who made his way in in various
entertainment related or or highly
financially speculative occupations
where a liberality with the truth was
customary and profitable and was not
looked upon as obscenely unethical
because it was customary and on the
other hand as Donald Trump the
relatively new Donald Trump as that as a
leader of the nation and particularly
the head of a vast faction of voters
adequate in their size to put him in the
White House he is absolutely truthful so
it depends which angle you take the
subject and I think when his critics say
that he's a liar because that's all they
say no he's a liar he's this first of
all it coming from holders of the
highest offices of national security who
lied repeatedly under oath and should be
and soon will be in front of the grand
jury which in your country means they're
out to jail that's right that's that's
absolutely right
you have people on television and not
not even just the Susan Rice's of the
world who lied to us not even just the
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton but
even up to Barack Obama lied right to
our face and we can we can check so many
of those lies the president would but I
don't believe he lied under oath in
fairness all president Russell I even
mr. Lincoln engaged in truthful
hyperbole at times but
but yeah I'm talking about lying under
oath which is a crime present anyway
yeah there's not the slightest that that
Hillary Clinton most of that entourage
of hers James clapper John Brennan James
Comey Andrew McCabe they all did that
and and it is a bit rich taking it from
the Democrats complaining about mr.
Trump being a liar when they are all
basically just waiting for indictment
right that's right they're just sitting
there
checking their iPhones you know so if
it's not today and the distinction that
they they seem not to make is the
difference between a lie and unsubtle T
so if Trump in this extreme political
way is able to stretch the truth let's
say he's very unsubtle about it this is
always the case it's so it's always
hyperbole so one of Donald Trump's first
acts when he became president of the
Trump Organization when he entered into
business as a young man was to hire Roy
Cohn the former counsel to commie
slamming Senator Joe McCarthy and
unsubtle man himself to defend the Trump
Organization
against a great many other people
including Rupert Murdoch and made a lot
of very respectable very successful
people of course and I'm a defender of
Joe McCarthy for that matter so I I
don't even consider him disreputable but
he it got a little carried far enough
okay yeah so Roosevelt Truman and
Eisenhower commies was going to was it
was a useful hyperbole so yeah but what
does that tell us the choice of Roy Cohn
relying on Roy Cohn this hard-charging
guy never never give up never defend and
what effect do you think if any Roy Cohn
had on Donald Trump we're all unlicensed
psychiatrists but as a historian I'm
always careful about mind-reading I in
my conversations with them mentioned him
now there was no particular reason why
he would but but I don't have the
impression he was an immense formative
influence I think when he even is from
the spacious areas of Southern
California it may not seem like a great
thing but as you would know and many of
your viewers would when you move from
from
z Street in Brooklyn to Manhattan it is
a trend it's not far in miles but it's a
tremendous cultural and sociological
change and and Donald Trump felt he
needed a roughed-up lawyer the last
thing he wanted is a sort of person that
many of us including me have a lot of
unpleasant experience with which are
ambiguous mealy-mouthed counsel who only
reach a point of a general mcarthur like
executive decision-making at sending out
their invoices the rest of the time
all they did was walk and that is not
what Donald wanted he wanted a fighter
and he wanted someone who would get in
the face of his opponents and drive them
crazy and Roy Cohn by all accounts were
the firm people who've just like them
too beautifully liked him and everyone
in between agreed that he was very
effective absolutely was guy to go to
and he also helped introduce him to a
lot of people that's right you you write
about how Donald Trump was very quick to
make good political connections he just
clearly seems like an operator and this
gets to the last point I won't ask you
to predict the future but I will ask you
to observe the character of Donald Trump
which is that Donald Trump appears to be
a survivor by your account and by all
that we know of the man he he just
survives he makes it out of bankruptcy
as he makes it out of difficult
situations all the time you opened the
account talking about the political
assassination of Richard Nixon and it
looks like there's deja vu all over
again but Trump is a survivor do you
think that the bureaucracy the Democrats
the media the political establishment
are are enough and have enough to
succeed in ousting him or do you think
that Trump has the character to
withstand that assault I am very very
completely satisfied that this is a
terrible mismatch and Donald Trump is
going to wipe the floor with them they
had no idea he is he is a fanatically
determined man and and he has in the
comparison of mr. Nixon he has the
advantage of this criminalization of
policy differences in this attempt to
harass and tear down presidents having
gone on for nearly 50 years prior to
trumping inaugurated
so so he knows how it's worked I mean
mr. Nixon who was a great president and
what happened to him was a disgrace a
terrible thing but to some degree he
cooperated inadvertently with his
enemies because he didn't handle it
properly didn't handle the issue proudly
but there's still not a serious case in
my opinion he committed any crimes but
he did squander his political governance
but there had not been discussion of the
impeachment of a president from more
than a century prior to Watergate and
Nixon had no idea how to deal with it
then after that you know Bill Clinton
fought it out and and and and and in
between you had the iran-contra business
where they never really got that close
to the president cuz Admiral Poindexter
said the boat you know the buck stops
here that was the end of it and and it
was near the end of his term and he was
a popular president but the the the
impeaches if you will
jumped mr. Nixon and there and there was
no relevant recent history Trump had all
of this pass to go by for tactical
planning purposes and and he has a
particularly strong and powerful nature
of self-defense and and these these
people if they had just given to me
reasonable Honeyman like most incoming
presidents get he would never bother all
the stuff about Hillary will be in jail
he wouldn't have done a thing but when
they attacked him they invented this
spurious nonsense about the collusion
with a fort from Reagan which no one
ever nominated by a major party to put
into the office of President in the US
whatever have done not Ehrenburg not
anybody and that was a declaration of
war and and it became a fight to the
death and he's going to kill him
I mean he is going and I don't mean
physically of course but politically
he's going to kill him and this is by
far the greatest scandal in the history
of the United States Watergate was
nonsense it was infected nonsense it was
a forced entry
there was no injury there was no
vandalism there was no economic damage
it was a bungled investigation that was
allowed to hemorrhage and was and was a
sort of primal scream therapy for the
left-wing press of the United States who
then who then spawned
generations of people who fancied
themselves to be investigative
journalists this this is the it's all
the shoe is on the other foot and you
see the balance tipping these accusers
of his are all going to prison and
that's where they belong I agree
entirely I agree with that account of
Watergate entirely because of me at one
point in support of something you said
just about how asinine his accusers are
the righteousness on this business of he
lies is at some point during the
campaign well on in the campaign he said
that Obama was the founder of Isis so
the fact-checking department of CNN
which has got to be the most under
worked organization they're all in Cabo
somewhere sipping pina coladas there's
the cargo Department of Sanitation under
Mayor Daley looked like an efficient
operation but the they laborious they
went through this process and put up and
both Blitzer darting around the studio
they're saying no Isis was founded by al
Baghdadi and aimed at other Iraqis and
and as if Trump meant that our famine
there sat there and raised the black
flag I mean it is so you're so
accurately imbecilic I can hardly
imagine it's happening after think it is
that's a wonderful way to put it is
imbecilic and you're just look and you
say I can't tell if these people are
being absurdly obtuse or if they're
really as dumb as they appear to be and
you have such a good point so many of
the political problems we're dealing
with is because this country took all of
the wrong lessons from Watergate from
that awful miscarriage of justice around
Watergate but we've got a different guy
in office now and I agree with your
estimation of it I also have to
recommend to everybody 'lord black I
will let you go finally you've been very
generous with your time everybody has to
go ahead and read this book it is really
really enjoyable it is it's a fair take
on Donald Trump it's not fawning it's
not attacking him it gives a really fair
look at it and it tells you so much that
our mainstream media won't tell us
because all of the fact checkers are in
Cabo sipping pina coladas Lorde black
thank you so much for being here I
really appreciate it thank you Michael
can I just leave you one phrase
it's the best and Gorky acute somebody
was on a panel with them of being
obnoxiously
teased it's a wonderful expression I'm
gonna have to start using that I'm gonna
start going to tweet that at Gorky now I
think then obnoxiously obtuse tune in to
the Michael Noel's show obnoxiously
obtuse thank you Lord black all right
before we cut we've got a lot of mailbag
to go to before we get to this point I
do want to make my most unpopular
opinion I'm going to alienate all of the
rest of my audience a note on Starbucks
a man so there's been a lot of talk in
Starbucks there was that black man who
was arrested or the cops were called on
him because he refused to purchase
anything and sat in a Starbucks for a
long time and it was all kind of a
strange situation and now a man in LA
cañada in California says that he is a
Hispanic man when he received a cup of
coffee with a racial slur on and I'll
just say it because you need to hear
this learn for the pun and it's not it's
sort of a silly slur is the [ __ ] is
the name of the that was on the cup so
how do we know this only his friend the
man's friend has been interviewed about
this and the friend doesn't speak in
English so he's just talking in Spanish
and what he explained though through a
translator is that apparently the guy's
name is Peter so he said Peter but I
don't know if the guy can speak English
his friends certainly can't speak
English so I said they wrote down [ __ ]
to Peter right who knows what happened I
don't know what happened it could have
been three options right it could have
been an honest mistake
and like a pretty stupid mistake but it
could have been an honest one never
never underestimate the stupidity of
people when you encounter them so it
could have been an honest mistake it
could have been an insult there could
have been some hateful racist employee
who said I'm gonna show this guy who
doesn't possibly speak English anyway
but I'll show him I'll get a kick out of
it okay could have been that or it could
have been a hoax it could have just been
a hoax I hate to there everyone's gonna
call me a bigot now for saying it could
be a hoax we've seen a ton of these
hoaxes all over the place we've seen it
on the issue of gay cakes you remember
there's like a gay guy said that someone
wrote a derogatory slur on his cake that
he bought in a bakery they
that he wrote it himself we've seen
racial hoaxes around the country we've
seen a lot of these sort of hoaxes I
suppose it could have been that the
question you have to ask yourself is
what is the point here is that is the
allegation that Starbucks is racist
Starbucks which makes a point to be as
progressive on questions of race as
possible as Starbucks which is so
overwhelmingly pushing all of those
progressive narratives that really
secretly it's this Confederate holdout
that hates racial minorities is that
what they're saying nobody believes that
everybody is just pretending it's a I
kind of like it on the Left because it's
a circular firing squad they all just
keep killing each other
rhetorically killing each other I don't
want that to be misinterpreted - now
that's gonna be the next boycott they're
gonna boycott the whole show you know
obnoxiously obtuse but the but the
question with Starbucks is what do
people really think nobody really
believes that Starbucks is racist on the
point of Starbucks I love Starbucks I
think it's just terrific I love
Starbucks I don't know it's overpriced
it's not overpriced Dunkin Donuts is
more expensive per ounce of coffee than
Starbucks Dunkin Donuts is dirty Dunkin
Donuts you know has that awful
fluorescent lighting most of the people
there don't speak English at the ones
that I've gone to they give you way too
much milk when you ask for just a drop
of milk
I go to my beautiful Starbucks it smells
great the baristas are smiling they have
silly purple hair and weird piercings I
don't care I find it sort of charming in
my barista I go in I can plug in my
computer I can sit I can use a clean
bathroom I can do work for hours and
hours I just have to buy a $2 cup of
coffee I get unlimited refills I love
Starbucks Starbucks has done more for
cities in this country and around the
world than any other organization in
history because it is the best public
bathroom in any any city in the history
of the world I love Starbucks the
lefties now don't like it because it's
allegedly racist conservatives don't
like it because it's so just obnoxiously
liberal I don't care it's a good company
it grew very big because it offered a
good product enough I will defend
Starbucks even poor Starbucks whom
nobody likes anymore we have a lot in
the mail back to get to but you've got
to go to Daley wire calm you have to I'm
sorry but we had a really good mailbag
today we have to burn through it in like
six minutes
so go to Daley why
calm right now what do you get you
getting me you get the end reclaim
ensure you get the magic Bureau show you
just ask questions in a mailbag like the
one that we're just about to go to you
can't ask questions in the conversation
the next one up is the big boss ben
shapiro and none of that matters mmmmmm
so these are the leftist tears this is
coming out of the leftist years tumblr
lord Conrad black has just suggested
that members of Hillary Clinton's cabal
could go to jail because they lied under
oath
they've we've seen the mainstream media
and the Democrats defending violent
Psychopaths gang members who behead
little children probably won't look that
good in November get this before it's
too late because otherwise you're gonna
drown and that'll be no good go to daily
wire comm we'll be right back with the
mailbag
we're gonna burn through these questions
because I want to spread all of the
cough fa to all of the people have asked
first from Amy hi Michael how would you
solve the homelessness problem in LA a
bulldozer probably or maybe a
steamroller in the Knowles mayorship in
LA I am only slightly kidding the answer
is police though because this has worked
in other cities it would work in LA we
have a terrible mayor in Eric Garcetti
we have an awful administration they're
destroying this city huge surges in
people sleeping on the street and
committing crimes on the street and it's
just awful because this mayor is
terrible the police should approach
homeless people every time they see them
and offer three choices shelters psych
wards or jail those that those are the
three choices shelters psych wards were
Jail so just to begin I would stop
subsidizing homelessness which the City
of LA does you can get a ton of benefits
you can get all of these really nice
things the police don't bother you they
construct whole city's terrible crime
ridden little tent cities under bridges
in otherwise nice neighborhoods they've
destroyed downtown LA I would stop
subsidizing homelessness and I would
start arresting people if they refused
shelter I forget who said this I think
Giuliani said this a few years ago
sleeping on the street is a
dysfunctional Act which harms the
individual who does it and society at
large people have no right to do it they
have no right to sleep on the streets
that is public property they have no
right to do it
Giuliani did this in the 90s he sent the
cops and said you either go to that
shelter you get arrested you go and it
worked it worked because nobody benefits
there's nothing compassionate about
letting these people sleep on the street
nothing compassionate at all it's cruel
to let people do it the compassionate
solution is to give these people help
and get them off the street nobody
benefits from letting vagabonds and
psychotics and drug addicts sleep there
least of all them there are AM place'll
homeless shelters in LA it creates a lot
of dangerous situations excuse me I saw
this in New Haven when I would live
there there was a tent city that sprung
up and everyone said oh that's so nice
let's all be compassionate
cool man I was one of the few people on
campus who said this is really a
terrible idea they said how cruel of you
to say that how awful and sure enough
within a matter of days a woman was
raped in that camp that bad things
happen when you let people sleep on the
street wouldn't tolerate it and a
compassionate and serious administration
wouldn't tolerate it from James James
hey Michael I'm sure you have recently
seen the video where the Pope answered
the question of a dead a theists son if
not I have seen it but I'll read this
for everyone else if not the boy said
his dad was an atheist but still
baptized his four children he asked if
his dad was going to heaven
the Pope replied something to the effect
of this was a father who loved his kids
he got them all baptized what do you
think do you think God would keep this
man out of heaven of course not in other
words the Pope answered that even though
the dad thought Jesus was as fake as the
tooth fairy this guy would still make it
into heaven because he baptized his four
kids what do you make of this thanks
James well I would say first of all I
can't blame Pope Francis for some poor
little boy comes up and says my daddy's
dead is he roasting in hell for eternity
was Pope Francis supposed to say yeah he
is you bet kid and you better watch out
or you'll end up there too
no but on the but again we're talking
about the truth not just comfort and
even on the mat the question of truth I
will point out the father baptized his
four kids why did he do that if he
thinks Jesus is just as fake as the
tooth fairy why did he baptize his four
kids I don't know our faculties of
reason are quite limited very frequently
we convince ourselves of things that we
know really aren't true I'm sort of
convinced that there aren't really
atheists at all nor McDonald has a bit
on this he says you know the reason
there can't be a theist is if you don't
believe in something you usually don't
spend all of your time thinking about it
like a atheists to that line an atheist
a vegan and a crossfitter walk into a
bar how do I know they told me within
two seconds the atheists they're always
talking about God they're always
grappling with God so I don't really buy
it and moreover I can't say who's in
heaven or who's in hell I really can't
do that I do not even know definitively
if Judas Iscariot is in hell I have my
suspicions you know but I you can't say
that indefinitely
had a conversion and repentance at the
very end as he's hanging on that noose
who knows so I really I think there
there is a lot to question in this
pontificate I've put up put that very
diplomatically but I actually don't
think his interaction with that kid is
one of them I think the answer was
perfectly fun from Dylan hello king of
trolls can I get a happy birthday thanks
Dylan no from Andy no I'm kidding okay
happy birthday Dylan from Andy hey
Michael do you foresee a breaking point
for the left it seems they pin
themselves into identity politics which
almost forces them to continue becoming
more and more extreme or I suppose
always forces them as a college student
I was surprised to see that a lot of my
classmates and friends find this way of
thinking useless and counterproductive
contrary to popular belief there are a
lot of us that actually crave genuine
debate and an exchange of ideas and it
seems to me that this postmodern way of
thinking makes honest conversation
impossible could we see a reduction in
this way of thinking in the Democrat
Party I do not see them being able to
win elections with this message or lack
thereof thanks yeah they're gonna have
to change or they're gonna die as a
political party again I'm speaking
rhetorically I just wanna be very clear
the the Democratic Party has has moved
in this way really since the ascendance
of Barack Obama into this very vicious
divisive angry identity politics which
says we don't like America we want to
fundamentally transform America we don't
like our countrymen you have privilege
you have this you have that and let's
free me during that period of time they
lost a thousand seats across the country
during the the presidency of Barack
Obama it lost a thousand seats across
the country they lost the house they
lost the Senate they ultimately lost the
presidency to Donald Trump you know what
a lot of people think Donald Trump
wasn't a great candidate for president I
won't go into that here but if you think
that the fact that even that candidate
was able to win tells you something
about the state of the Democrats so I
hope they don't change I hope they keep
keep it up keep it right up and the
Republicans are gonna rule for the next
century from James we'll get a couple
more good sir Michael canola's according
to the political spectrum is Islam
considered extreme right-wing religious
conservative or has it been co-opted by
the leftists in America in Europe for
identi politics and is now a far left
ideology similar to fascism particularly
National Socialism
sidenote thank you for
keeping the cigar industry alive as well
I'm also an enthusiast particularly of
the Maduro variety great commentaries
always Jim a very good question the left
certainly has embraced Islam they've
invented that word Islamophobia to smear
people who don't want to get their heads
chopped off or something I don't I don't
know exactly what the word means but
with regard to the left-right spectrum
here I don't think you can fit
everything neatly into those categories
and frankly even using those terms
sometimes plays into the modernist hand
it it doesn't really get to what you're
talking about the terms right and left
they come from the French Revolution in
1789 relatively recently in historical
terms supporters of the king and
religion at the National Assembly were
seated on the president's right and
supporters of the French Revolution were
seated on his left that's where we get
it from that's the whole place left and
right and the French Revolution
referred to seating not necessarily
ideology so and actually at the time the
right sort of opposed this breakdown
because they opposed shallow factions
and political parties but because the
left-right spectrum originates in this
radical modernity and the French
Revolution it doesn't really capture the
variety of political views conservatives
just to use one of the examples you give
conservatives always quibble over
whether fascism is on the left or the
right in some ways it seems like it's
right-wing because there's a great love
of country you could say in fascism but
in some ways it's obviously left-wing
it's atheistic usually hostile to
religion hostile to many traditions
collectivist so it seems rather
left-wing there too really what you
could say is it's just modern fascism
and communism they're two sides of the
same coin now this doesn't work when you
try to apply it to older ideas what
would you call the Aristotelian system
of ethics would you call that left or
right I don't know predates left and
right by thousands of years Islam also
predates left and right by a thousand
years aslam is not modern what what is
Islam Islam is a religion that grew out
of a Christian heresy in the seventh
century and involved aspects of Arab
nationalism pan-arab nationalism and
came as a strange new twist on the
Abrahamic faiths so I don't really think
it's a question of right or left I think
you should expand the thought there and
make it a question of right or wrong on
that point I'll say Islam crucially
denies the crucifixion of Christ
the conquest of death so when you're
trying to answer that question it's a
good good one to ask can I do one more
will you let me do one more I can do one
why I can only do one more let's make it
a good one let's make sure that we can
do a really good one okay all right
we'll just do the next one and then
we'll just have to get the rest of them
next week from Emily hey Michael I've
been reading a hagiography about the
life of st. Catherine of Siena it's been
a great read but it leaves me with a
nagging question st. Catherine had a
vision of God at the age of seven she
was extremely aware from a young age of
the presence of God and his importance
in her life why is it that God would
give her major confirmation that he
exists but others languish in a sea of
uncertainty their entire lives her life
thanks to revisions was certainly not an
easy one but it does seem like a life of
virtue would be so much easier if you
have zero doubts about God's existence
thanks Emily I love st. Catherine of
Siena but I don't think a life of virtue
is necessarily easier if you have more
evidence than others of God's existence
just take st. Peter and Judas let's take
Judas first Judas spends Christ's
ministry with Christ he sees Christ
raised dead people to make them living
again he sees Christ multiply fishes and
to feed thousands of people and bread to
feed thousands of people he sees him
heals the lame and the blind and the
sick and walk on water and then he
betrays him but he saw it he know he
sees Christ as who he is he sees the
incarnation of God he betrays him anyway
st. Peter st. Peter sees the
Transfiguration of Christ on the
mountain he sees this unbelievable
vision you knows for certain the father
reveals to Peter that Christ is the
Christ and what does he do he denies him
three times what he doesn't he denies
him three times so I don't know that
that's necessarily the case it just in
one's own experience if you've ever had
a numinous experience or religious
experience of God it's unmistakable when
it happened
it's unmistakable it's also ineffable so
it's not much use trying to explain it
but it's unmistakable when it happens
use you're shocked by this you're in all
holy fear and then like five minutes
later you just start sitting again you
know it's not it's not funny it's kind
of sad but just you have this experience
and then regardless you fall away
because it's a fallen world and that's
an aspect of human nature so I don't
know about that the evidence for God is
ample and there were no good arguments
for atheism there just temptations
basically they're just temptations and
all of us have temptations st. Catherine
of Siena as well okay hope that helps
there are other so many other good
questions we'll just bring them back
next week have a good weekend I'll see
you on Monday I'm Michael Doyle this is
the Michael Noel's show I will see you
Monday
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austen Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you